a relationship so what happens in like a
lesbian relationship is I don't know
well again
everything the man says everything that
was said is fine for relationships
there's I just there's not like a
masculine feminine like when you start
talking about you're going to talk to
your partner you're going to make sure
that they understand where you're coming
from hopefully you love each other and
you know each other hopefully you both
have each other's best interests at
heart and then you advise it that's at
the end of the day someone wears the
pants like someone's leading and
someone's following it's it's like no
sometimes wait and sometimes it's
reverse but at some at some point like
you have to trust someone's leadership
that it's gonna depend on the domain
that you guys are experts in right so
you said you were a mechanic right so
I'm guessing that traditionally men are
gonna have to say over the car because
men tend to know but I'm guessing you
probably know more than your husband
does right and if he comes back with a
50-pound bill for blinker fluid you're
probably gonna say you're probably gonna
make fun of him right but you know
something right I just put on knows and
as you must probably know yes I'm a
mechanic
but he's more stable-minded than me and
as you know from the car that I
picked you up in right because I must
have been having a blind non-mechanic
feminine moment where I just went in and
asked for the cheapest car with four
doors and you saw it the car's a piece
of it's for somebody single it's
not for someone that's got three
grandchildren because free granted of me
fills the car but whereas he hasn't seen
the car yet because I didn't discuss it
with him and he's going to look at me
and say why did you get that car yes I
could take it back but I've decided to
punish myself for being such a stupid
woman and she was in such a stupid car
when I was feeling in my most feminine
moments so yeah I can do that but
whereas even though I'm a trained
mechanic
enema nails and there's certain things
that he will do in the no I won't say
that most of the things he will do I
always say your break like he's doing
but he expects me to do the brake light
sure because I'm trying to do just the
brake line I'm just saying I'm just
saying that in every relationship like
both sides are going to know more things
than the other side but like so there
are going to be some things where the
husband is going to have like the grand
Authority but not because he's the man
uh but just because that's the stuff
that he knows
she knows about them but the last
decision you see with me we were discuss
stumps discuss stuff
and I will say this and he will say that
and then
I might be right and he'll say you know
what go with you or he might be right
and I'll say go with you but if we come
to a stalemate me I would say you know
what we're gonna go with you because the
decision is all yours because that's the
it's the fan me as a woman I
will say you know you made that decision
so the final decision is always his
whoever he agrees with me or whoever he
you agree however I agree with him I
prefer the final decision to be his
because
I just think personally the ideal
situation is when you're with a guy that
you can trust his decision making and I
think the girls and the girls that I see
where they wear the pants in the
relationship they're miserable oh my God
it just depends on the thing like any
there are plenty of women where guys
wear the pants and they're miserable too
there are lots of people in naturally
miserable relationships does it happen
both ways sure at times I've just seen I
think that when women wear the pants
they're miserable yes
can I just say why does someone have to
wear the pants why can't
why can't we make decisions together
like he said if you're more if you have
more expertise in that field then say
okay like if I'm I'm trying to make a
decision with my man now I know about
properties right say he doesn't know
anything about properties I'm gonna be
like oh babe because I've bought a
property this is what I'm gonna tell you
and because he's probably like men know
more about cars I don't know about cars
I will never tell my man anything about
cars because I I assume because men seem
to know more about cars and if he has a
nice car he he's been driving for a long
time I'm gonna think you know what
that's his field why does it have to be
someone wear the pants do you know
something right that's what women feel
to understand when they hear about a
submissive woman do I look like a woman
that this does what her man says no I
want to take for instance you my man is
a saver
I like to invest in property he has got
more money in the bank than me I have
got more properties than him and even
when it comes to getting properties he
was a saver he was like no I need to
save money whatever and I was like this
is what I think you know he said go with
it you know what I was right it doesn't
make a difference
because he made the final decision
because a selfish man
a man that just wants to feel all full
of himself would just go with what he
wants and we're not talking the lady in
the red coat I'm sorry we're not talking
about that we're talking about where
you've got a man that leads and a proper
man when you've got a man that you can
trust he will take into account what you
said he could be taking account what he
says and he would weigh up the pros and
cons and he will come out with the best
decision for you whoever it means you
side with him or whatever it means
inside of you and if he's not sure
he will either say you know what if he's
a stubborn big-headed bullish man he was
like you know what my name will so I'm
gonna go no when I was talking about
Brandon property my man didn't agree
with me and I explained you know what
this this this this but it seemed like
an impossibility to him in his mind as a
natural saver but he was like you know
what go for it now we've got the
properties he's got the money I haven't
got no money if I need money I'll go to
him but on paper I've got more money but
in reality he's got more cash so you
just don't go with a man just because
because a lot of women think that oh I
might know more about this but he's the
mass he has to make the fine decision
best lack of respect if a man respects
you he will take into account your
decisions your research your
qualifications before he makes the final
decision and if a man is going to go
with all your knowledge all your
experience all your decision making and
what you've been doing for a lifetime
and go against it but don't you think
about you don't you think you're talking
about skills in a man that is a man that
has lived a man that's matured a man
that has had relationships learn about
himself and others we're talking about
men in their 20s and 30s that have yet
to become exactly and I think so we
cannot we cannot have the same attitude
at all you're talking generationally
completely different I think the value
basis the way that they are raised are
different you are your expectations for
our 2023 men that have been raised with
sometimes very little Foundation You're
Expecting so much for them to have all
of these qualities that your man of X
years and X age and big big age are
having
I think the point is to pick a good man
that you can 100 but I'm talking about
we're here now we're here trying to find
this good man in the mecca we're like oh
no the nonsense
hold on hold on hold on I've been
listening to like I haven't even said
nothing for ages yeah like it comes down
to who you pick yeah 100 it comes down
to you pick so you can say all of this
oh yeah oh we're trying to find these
Good Men At what age are you trying to
find these good and where where are you
trying to find can I can say thank you
riches yeah right
you're saying about picking the problem
I find nowadays is that the woman is
picking don't let the women pick the Men
supposed to pick no the problem
it's what um Camilla yeah yeah the
problem is at 25 there are no men like
this okay if you're a 22 year old woman
you're not gonna find a 25 year old guy
that's ready to take charge and Lead
everything no that is true that is true
absolutely true that's absolutely true
I'm so sorry I know there are a lot of
children on those panels but you're not
gonna find a 25 year old guy that has
all of it when the average kid gets out
of school today at like 22 23 years old
you're thinking how when in England you
finish college
no you don't university university
I'm sorry we call it different things in
America yeah if in University if you
finish that at 20 to 23 there's no way
full degrees
at 24 25 as a man you are not going to
have all the faculty that you were when
you reach 30 35 you don't have that
lived experience yet to know what it's
like to lead a household to live a life
to exist in like the world and and to
navigate
is so funny that you guys are the first
ones to say that we have two high
expectations and then come and tell us
that we're not picking the right men and
that we're just picking responsible you
can date an older guy if you if you
think that you need a 35 year old guy
I'm all right come on
did you say
I want a young man just like myself so
we can relate together again like I
don't want anything
you guys keep talking about how you need
a man to lead yeah I already know myself
I'm an adult you know I've spent a lot
of time with myself I am in I'm in tune
with myself what I want is partnership
yes my Lord I want a man that we can
actually share its experiences together
our leaders yeah I think the problem is
when I listen to Pearl and rich as an
artist a little bit mainly you two guys
it feels like you guys are saying that
women need to look for fathers
can I just say something when I met my
man we're both in our 20s thank you
and the thing is it's in the 80s but if
you had the same standards now which I
have met some really good young men they
had the same standards as my men have
but you know what the women don't want
them because they're average men well
all your videos about these videos
when I met my man I was average he was
average he was sexy as hell and all the
young girls wanted him do you know what
I mean but we were both average people
and he was he was always sensible from
your family planning to settle why can't
I want amazing
this is the thing
why would you want why can't you get it
yeah
it's amazing he's always been amazing he
was amazing when I'm older than him
[Laughter]
it's like everybody's saying I need to
have it as average as average why I
ain't average I am not average I'm gonna
let you know right what makes you not
average because if I look at my age mate
my successes my achievements my
personality my drive my motivation is on
it for once are you a single parent
because sometimes as a single parent
because you've been in the relation
they've been there before you've got
different expectations oh I'm saying I
didn't start as a single parent I met my
husband and I had a child nobody nobody
meets as a single
parents my man was a single parent I'm
not just going against the women my man
was a single parent too
yeah
there's how many people in here wait
eight most of us are average most people
are average can I say something and when
you talk about drive that's the top
things that men look for
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible